Britain is broken the theme of this
March in London bringing together people
from across the country many protesters
said they were worried Public Services
could be eroded further under prime
minister Rishi sunak one of the areas
under severe pressure is the mental
health sector within the National Health
Service the NHS
tree and this big economic crisis is
going to make it so much worse
okay can't help me
because they don't have the money either
I work for a mental health charity and I
am seeing people
at risk of death or dying because of
this government directly as a result I
see it every day the protesters are
motivated by a range of issues and
concerns but something that unites them
is worries about further cuts to public
spending in other words austerity
[Applause]
on Saturday a planned strike on the
railways was canceled after an offer of
unconditional talks from employers but
unions plan further industrial action in
this and other sectors pushing for pay
rises in line with inflation to combat
the cost of living crisis Al Jazeera
spoke to apsana begum a politician whose
London constituency has one of Britain's
highest rates of child poverty with an
increasing number of families using food
banks
over the last 12 years and our services
another common theme was a demand for a
general election We're Gonna Save Our
welfare state and we're going to kick
these stories out of Parliament there
have been two changes in leadership
since Boris Johnson quit as prime
minister earlier this year and the
conservatives are considering scrapping
some Manifesto pledges that saw them win
back in 2019.
whatever happens in the coming months
public anger is unlikely to die down
Nadine barber Al Jazeera London